we all have this desires and we all keep
fulfilling these desires we have this
wrong concept of Happiness let me work
hard let me get all the money let me buy
all of that stuff let me get all the
phones let me have those palaces let me
have my dream house let me have my dream
car and I'll be happy your dream and
there's nothing wrong with dreaming
there's nothing wrong with earning but
to dream that this is what will make you
happy I'm sorry to say after you cross a
certain limit no it's all a status game
it has no value it can't add more value
to your life it's all a status game
again don't get me wrong I'm not saying
don't turn I'm just saying don't make
the mistake of equating your happiness
with something that only has utility
value need motivation watch a top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best geworko paltas and my my
take on his top 10 was a success
enjoy
rule number two gain experience of
course when we're talking about
measurements we're measuring in on in
one way yes correct so this the data and
the statistics would be in one space yes
so in that particular space we would say
we list here if we start measuring
basing some other yardstick as a
statistical measurement probably have a
different whole different statistics
available to us nevertheless having said
that I think uh
I I often say
whether you drive a BMW or a Rolls-Royce
it's not the car the happiness it's the
journey
when the focus shifts overtly to the car
then the journey
you're compromising with your experience
car is important a good car is great no
problem but when your focus is overtly
on that you're compromising with your
journey
I say often it's not an iPhone or a
Samsung it's the quality of your
conversation on that phone that gives
you that experience of happiness but
when your attention moves from the
quality of conversations to the quality
of your phone overtly you're kind of
compromising with your experience
I often say that it's not the watch that
whether it's a Rolex or a desert or
whatever it is you know or uh Georgia
money whatever brand of Rado
or a breedling whatever watch you wear I
really don't think it's the watch that
gives you that happiness it's how you
utilize the time on that watch that
gives you that experience but when your
focus shifts from utilizing your time to
your watch and flaunting that watch I
think we are compromising with our
experience I don't think it's the house
that's made of bricks and cement that
brings us the happiness with the whether
it's in Malabar Hill with the most fancy
Furnishings inside and a massive space I
think it's the quality of our
relationships in that house and
that bring this happiness the home that
brings us happiness so it's not India or
America or any place in the world it's
anybody
anybody who prioritizes things
achievements of things and starts
equating the quality of our their life
with those things we'll definitely have
a compromise standard of experience
whereas those who prioritize the quality
of their Journey the quality of their
relation and not saying the things
shouldn't be there absolutely not saying
that I'm just saying equating happiness
to that
is where the problem is where the
problem is because then you know today
and and it also comes from what's
considered a social social standard of
being being accepted with a social
standard being accepted as cool
today you're not judged for who you're
not accepted for who you are except for
the car you drive or the area you live
in or the class of
uh an airplane that you fly on and a
flight that you fly on so in a in a
society where the standards of your
success are so shallow then the pressure
to conform that if I don't have this if
I don't if I'm not at this party I'm
this form one the fear of missing out
I'm missing Ireland big taste big thing
but who created it the standard that we
made that this is what happens means
but if we understand that there are
Finer Things that bring us happiness
these things have utility value let's
use them
use the best stuff no problem use the
best stuff who say you don't have a
Rolls Royce but if you think Rolls-Royce
makes you happy I'm sorry you know have
the fanciest house who says don't have
it but you think it's the house that
makes you happy I'm not sure if bricks
and cement can make me happy
you know rule number three have hope I
must tell you
oh God
just how the world is when you're high
up you don't know what to say there
you're not just I was in America I was
just in America in February I was flying
from uh New York JFK Airport to go to uh
Detroit
and it was an airline called Spirit
Airlines
and in the morning they were selling
alcohol
so I asked the stewardess I guess your
airline is in very high Spirit you know
they were selling spirits in the morning
itself oh goodness
turbulence not in control
take off not in control Landing not in
control choice
in control
the takeoff of life is our birth
no control
I can't change my looks
I was born the way I was
poor family some are born very smart and
handsome someone are bad so handsome
some Affairs some are dark some are
green some are yellow some are one in
the U.S some are born in Indian some are
born in America Hindu families Muslim
family some are born in Jew families
what control do you have
over the takeoff did you choose your
mothers and fathers
do you have any control no control at
all and in the landing
death
when does Hope and
God is the
is the Hope in life you don't have to be
hopeless failure is not the end of the
world someone insulting you is not the
end of the world a Health crisis is not
the end of the world a divorce a breakup
is not the end of the world
foreign
problems during the Journey of your life
from birth to death take off to Landing
as the Journey of your life goes there's
clouds there's wind speeds tremendous
turbulence which is completely beyond
your
control are people in your control
what people say about you behind your
back is your internal control
what people think of you is it in your
country you can try to be good but can
you control people
in New York when I was there recently
one guy came up to me after my talk and
said you're the egoistic person a most
egoistic person I've ever seen I don't
even know him
I'm a human being
even I have feelings and emotions
can't just come and slap you on your
face and I won't even use the words you
used against me straight on my face and
then wrote a wrong email to me that
email is on my phone just in case you
feel I'm Live come and check out
God bashing me with words like oof
what can I do
when a Health crisis comes
cancer happens to someone for no fault
of his or hers
[Music]
when an examiner asks Google
[Music]
we all know what can you do
what can you do
nothing right
therefore between this journey called
birth and death there's only one thing
in our control
our choices
the choices we make are completely
in our control choice
however take advantage of the time in
between you know and as I say when
you're born people love you
and when your people when you die people
love you in between you have to manage
you know kind of really amazing how
people can be rule number four practice
questioning let's not look at viewpoints
from any particular lens right
let us look at life and spirituality as
a process of learning right and when we
are talking about a process of learning
there's no Learning Without questioning
it doesn't matter what feed doesn't
matter what background if spirituality
if religion is a process of Education
right and learning I'm not sure if
education and learning would happen
without questioning in a dialogue a
dialogue right I remember I think was it
uh I it was easy door Rabbi was his name
physicist if I'm not wrong this
gentleman got a Nobel Prize Okay And the
reporter has asked him they said they
asked him said sir you are now a Nobel
Laureate you have a Nobel Prize so what
made you different from all the children
in your neighborhood
you come from a Jewish background they
would Jewish background from the judai
tradition all friends all from the same
neighborhood
made you
whereas they probably believe or
whatever else how did you stand out to
be a physicist or a scientist
[Music]
or replied he said
they are doing exceedingly well and
they're doing very well they're still
amazing they're my great good friends he
said
and then he said
every single time all of these kids who
are friends were in the same school we
studied in the same school somewhere in
the same class same grade
said when we came back home
most of my friends when they got back
home their mothers would
ask them
did you answer the question teachers
questions right today
and he said whenever I got back home my
mom said to me did you ask intelligent
and right questions to your teacher
today wow absolutely because education
learning is an evolution
and that evolution is not possible
without questioning right Reckless
questioning is something that we may
abandon absolutely you know Reckless
questioning meaninglessly is something
that Pete that all of us would agree to
them but genuine question questioning
for clarification for understanding in
fact I I tell people please don't accept
what I'm saying challenge me on what I'm
saying
challenge me because it's an education
it's the process of Educational Learning
otherwise it's Blind Faith I'm saying it
so you're accepting it right
so I feel therefore religion can be
questioned it should be questioned I I'm
not saying religion religion I'm saying
if it's a process of Education
questioning and learning must be a part
of it right if this is my academic
material education is my degrees I get
religion is meant to offer me spiritual
education
and if it's a part of spiritual
education
how can education be without questioning
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five correct your
mistakes when you write
you will most certainly
end up making mistakes
what's truly great
is that
right behind you is attached an eraser
and you can actually
correct
[Music]
that mistake
and
once again
right
the right thing
ladies and gentlemen
Even in our lives we make so many
mistakes
and what's amazing
is God has given us the opportunity the
chance
to erase them to correct them and to
rewrite our stories
we all make mistakes I remember
I once went for a program and a
Gentleman came to me and said uh
prabhuji I'm your fan
I said why he said your talks are really
inspiring especially the jokes I said
what about the points man he said the
points are good but the jokes are great
I said to him come on all the jokes are
only meant to really pass on the message
and drive home the point
and just as we were talking a little boy
came running and I said your son right
he said yeah
and just following the boy came a lady I
said your daughter right
and the man turned blue
and the lady was like all smiles a year
to your smile because she was not his
daughter she was actually his wife
the guy turned to his wife and said
prabhujikujada seriously
oh my God I realized God I had made a
big mistake there by asking if it was
his daughter when she was actually his
wife we all make mistakes
now anyone who comes to me with people
around I never ask whether this is your
son or daughter or wife or father or
mother I just ask can you kindly
introduce me to everyone please
simple isn't it
yes we make mistakes we should learn
from those mistakes
erase them
correct them
and never repeat them rule number six
solve problems everybody looks for pro
solutions to problems isn't it
foreign
us from experiencing happiness
that's a big thing that's stopping us
from making happiness happen who is it
that doesn't want to make happiness
happen
it's problems that's nothing it could be
a health problem could be financial
problem
could be a relationship problem
could be a business problem
[Music]
helping you from crafting your habits
we all want to do it all want the
solutions to this problems isn't it
there's no lock in the world that was
created without a key
not a single lock in the world was
created without a key I don't know why
would somebody make a lock without a key
every lock that was made was created
with a key
and so every problem every challenge
every issue that's there in our life
which is like a lock and seems like a
deadlock a dead end
the key
it's not seen now it's not visible to us
right now you don't know where the key
is
we are searching for the case
how do I get a solution to the problem
you know what
every law comes with a key in every
problem with a solution
some of your problems can actually be
solved
and some of your problems
literally cannot be solved but can be
solved by becoming stronger to face them
that's the key
that's the key you know
what do you do when you have a mentally
challenged child born to you
a child with special needs born to you
what do you do
[Music]
the solution then there is a solution
there is a key
but the key is not this will change
the key is
you will have to OK stronger to
hurt and solve that problem
Solutions
bhaglo
[Music]
right there's only two things you can do
run away
[Applause]
participate face and deal with it
[Music]
which is why a lot of times I say
just because someone is happy
and just because someone is smiling
doesn't mean they don't have issues
doesn't mean they don't have problems
doesn't mean they don't have challenges
just because
[Music]
the difference
is they've chosen
to deal with whatever they can do with
their problem they deal with it but
they've chosen to shift their attention
to something else in their life okay
if your attention is always on your
problem and only problems are on your
mind constantly just occupied by issues
problems challenges the difficulties the
troubles the emotional hurt the wounds
that have happened how are you going to
have to make happiness happen
with all of that going on you have to do
what we have to do to deal with it
when people smile and happy that doesn't
mean they don't have problems in life
chosen
the shift
their attention
to something that can make happiness
happen and both are exclusive one
doesn't cancel another rule number seven
don't go too fast tell you something
how many of you know this guy
I'm not too sure if you know him
the gentleman is one of the most finest
violent players on planet Earth
his name Joshua Bell
his Wyman costs 4 million pounds
[Music]
his violin costs that's the worth of his
violent Joshua Bell
Washington Post they decided to do a
experiment
they put Joshua well whenever Joshua
Bell would perform concerts
people would have to pay anywhere in the
range of 300 to 500 for an hour to
listen
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and he performed some of the most
amazing gigs
[Music]
foreign that's how he played
incredible pieces masterpieces
and Washington Post did a research to
see
within an hour's time of his playing
how many people stopped by how many
people passed by him how many people
stopped by to hear what he had to play
and how much money did he earned coins
[Music]
1097 people
1097 people passed by during this music
that he was playing in the one hour in
the subway
ready to hear how many actually stopped
to listen to him
any wild guesses
a 1097 people his concert Halls would be
full all the time seven people stood
there
and guess how much money he got in the
Hat a ticket
32 in one hour
and Washington Post
just explode to say what had happened it
was the evening hour everyone was in a
Rush
when you're in a rush
and you go too fast in life
you cannot have a spiritual experience
this is why
press a pause
[Music]
in your 20s to 30s every now and then
uh Mars introspect
relish things in life
the best things to relish are the
simplest things in life not the
complicated life of intense rule number
eight develop professional Wellness what
really is important is in the world
today we are talking a lot about
Wellness
physical wellness is spoken about mental
Wellness is spoken about emotional
Wellness is spoken about I don't hear a
lot of people talking about professional
Wellness you know and when we're talking
about professional Wellness I'm not just
talking about somebody who's doing well
professionally there's a difference
between doing well and feeling well
right doing well is your expertise that
takes you to the heights of your success
and achievements pays you well but
feeling well you love what you do and
you enjoy what you do and a huge chunk
of people out there are doing well not
sure if they're feeling well so back in
the day when I was with Hewlett Packard
I was thinking to myself that I'm doing
well
paid well but am I feeling well with my
work I'm going to have to spend 90 000
hours doing this stuff
and there was a big fat no
that came out of my mind I I'm good at
it but I don't think I'm cut for this
obviously the next question that came in
my mind was then what am I cut for
absolutely why and that's when I
realized that for me my passion was not
so much to work with systems and
machines as an engineer my passion was
to work with people to explore life to
understand life help people with their
lives the one way to go about it was to
probably study psychology but then I
also had a spiritual comment
so I thought why not explore my own
spiritual calling and see if I have
answers to life and dealing with life in
spiritual philosophy and wisdom which
can then help people as well so that's
what made me take that plunge and switch
over from or shall I say upgrade from
electrical engineering to Lifestyle
engineering my mind
you might say
and it's very fulfilling it's been 25 26
years no regrets so far touchwood it's
been very fulfilling the journey has
been incredible very satisfying
I also want to say one thing that I took
a risk yes you know when you take that
plunge leaving the secure and going to
the insecure moving from the certain to
the uncertain moving from the road
that's taken to The Road Less Traveled
all right do you take a risk and I feel
I took an uncalculated risk it was
uncalculated you didn't know what was
coming ahead
but when the passion inside of you is
burning so
powerfully it's like a guy in love with
a girl
burning so much it's irresistible
it's irresistible
when I do tell people I say that look
don't take such kind of risks though
because you have real life issues
Financial liabilities mortgages to pay
terminally ill patients at home often
right and you you need to look at that
side and if you take that plunge and
just jump straight away into following
your passion just so that you feel well
that's right you may not be able to
address this real world absolutely I I
tell a lot of youngsters who come to me
for advice about writing I say look that
the early days when I got into the world
of writing I was writing in the middle
of the night but I was still putting in
a full day of work and so my one piece
of advice to them is usually don't lose
the day job because it's very difficult
to write when you're hungry you know
but you did precisely that you quit the
day job I did it and that's what I heard
advice
I'm saying keep your day job
well so your financial needs are
addressed but also pursue your passion
and what you love to do so that you feel
well and maybe one day you feel well you
will also be your mainstream profession
who knows you know rule number nine Find
Unity in diversity how many of you could
cook
[Music]
how many of you
[Music]
how many of your cooking is disastrous
[Music]
terrible terrible is an understatement
if you cook a little bit you know chunk
is fantastic and one thing I like about
chunk is
foreign
[Music]
all the ingredients of the chunk are so
different and so diverse right right
temperature
you put
salt salt will give taste to the
preparation and always remain in the
background
[Music]
healthy
[Music]
[Music]
groups
[Music]
and if you're Gujarati then you have
some sugar
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but so diverse isn't it so different
[Music]
purpose
Spirit ache your preparations
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
first ingredients
how relation
[Music]
don't expect your husband wife parent
child friend to be the same
diversity is what makes life beautiful
relationships are like that
[Music]
and Rule Number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is learn
the attitude of gratitude in India
in a place called Bihar
a small little place called Patna
there's a guy who studied in a high
school there
and came out of Patna
to become a big business Giant
and once he returned back to Patna
and when he got back to Patna
he thought let me go
see one of my school friends whom I was
with in school studying for about eight
nine years
he went to see his school friend the
place where his school friend lived was
you know small Narrow Lane so he's a
businessman now he couldn't drive in his
car so he parked the car outside decided
to walk into the lane
[Music]
he heard that his school friend whom he
studied with for several years in school
had turned out to be a priest in a
temple
because his father was a priest
they're not met for a long time
so he go went to see his friend who was
now a priest
and firstly the friend didn't even
recognize the guy you know he's a big
businessman still a priest and then they
kind of got up and started talking and
they started sharing their hearts and
catching up for whatever long time had
been gone on and then this priest
looking at this new my friend would come
after a long time not even knowing what
he
was not even knowing that he's a
businessman said to him
Hey look
look you're not living in a big city
if just in case you want to do something
and start something and you need some
financial help
I've saved up this 25 000 rupees from a
long time
I'd like to give it all away to you to
start business this business
and this businessman was a friend
God his heart was touched with this man
all he has is 25 000 rupees
and these 25 000 Rupees is willing to
give it all away to me
this is Miss nine it made such an impact
on the heart of this businessman
that on CNBC this businessman was being
interviewed by one of his friends whom I
just met this evening here right here
was interviewing this businessman
and after asking the sutras for his
success ask this businessman would you
like to share the story
and this businessman shared the story
with a grateful heart remembering
his memory hadn't gone weak he had
remembered that this guy had offered me
this 25 000 Rupees to start something a
venture and that's all he had who with
deep gratitude remembered this man in
his memory that he was off willing to
give
ladies and gentlemen gratitude is about
memory about remembering what people
have done for us remembering what people
do for us how they come forth to help us
and so many have done that for us
do you know something in the game of
life you're playing a cricket match
against an entity called the mind
no one on planet Earth can stop you from
accomplishing and achieving what you
want if you can
backed
against the Googlies
that the Mind pulls at you how many of
you have experienced that the mild bowls
Googlies
[Music]
good
when it comes to exercising and jogging
how many of you know that the Mind bowls
Googles matcha
soja
how many of you have trouble in studying
raise your hands as students
[Music]
by WhatsApp don't get distracted by
internet pornography don't get
distracted by Twitter don't get
distracted by Facebook study don't get
distracted by birds to do bird watching
study all these distractions
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll tell you something
my God why because the mind doesn't want
you to win the game of life
how many of you wanted to wake up early
in the morning Regents only wanted I
asked
wanted to wake up early in the morning
and how many of you have done something
called as
setting an alarm clock
and then after setting the alarm clock
that's an alarm
whether you want it or not it rings
and when it rings the Mind puts its
first googly
what does the Mind do by putting the
googly makes you clean bold when you do
the first snooze
you are out
you are out
if you snooze you are up
I want to say one thing just one and
probably this will change the direction
of your life you know something when you
snooze the alarm
what happens
you decide to give into the mind's ball
and this is how your morning Begins by
giving into the mind
foreign
[Music]
giving in sleeping five minutes extra is
no problem the problem is you develop
the attitude of giving in
you tell yourself that what I decided
last night is not as important what is
important is what the mind says
because we listen I'll tell you
something my humble advice because it's
not just about getting up in the morning
it's about every aspect of life whether
it's your work if you're working whether
it's your study if you're studying
whatever we do
the problem is
it's not about one thing it reflects in
every area of life
is
[Music]
don't allow that snooze many of you have
many of you some of you have commented
and asked me this question that all this
sounds easier than done
it's easy to say these things easy to
listen to these things when it comes to
practical implementation application and
dealing with these things in real life
it seems very difficult it seems very
hard but that's very true what you've
said is perfectly true
because only the wrong things come very
easy the right things that we need to do
in our life don't come that easily
you know when we do the wrong things
they give us that momentary pleasure and
they're extremely easy to do
although they give us that momentary
pleasure and they're easy to do in the
long run however
we have to pay a very high price in
terms of our physical emotional mental
and spiritual well-being although they
give us pleasure and they are easy
God they really cause a lot of trouble
later
and the right things they cause pain in
the beginning they're painful to do
a lot of hard work they don't come easy
and if you just are willing to bear that
initial pain that initial hard work that
initial discomfort and that initial
could be a long time actually
in the long run
these right things these right habits
pay back a massive premium to us in
terms of sustained pleasure
safe pleasure which has a very high
shelf value and it is not at all
destructive to our overall sense of
well-being this kind of pleasure coming
from the right things Lord Krishna calls
these pledges in the bhagavad-gita as
satwik Pleasures or Pleasures in the
mode of goodness they cause pain in the
beginning
discomfort in the beginning
but they pay back a huge premium in
terms of sustained High shelf Pleasures
on the other hand Lord Krishna calls
this short-term Pleasures come that come
by doing wrong as Pleasures in the mode
of ignorance or thumb sick pleasures
these Pleasures are momentarily very
exciting thrilling exhilarating
and they're easy to go
but in the long run we have to pay a
huge price therefore ladies and
gentlemen do not worry so much about
what is easy
or hard worry about what is right and
wrong
the right things may be hard but we
should be doing it in a long term
interest the wrong things may come easy
but we should be avoiding them in our
long-term interest
therefore even of being polite sensitive
Swift supportive kind to others may be
hard even if putting all these things
that we've spoken in the last couple of
days into practice base sounds very hard
and difficult but that's the right thing
to do ladies and gentlemen in our
transformative Journey we have to worry
about the right thing to do not the easy
thing to do and right things require a
lot of hard work but bit by bit as we
work hard we can get there is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sorry with the art history students
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
chapter
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a man got lost in the desert and had
exhausted all the water he had carried a
couple of days ago
he knew for sure that if he didn't get
some water he would certainly die
although completely exhausted the man
didn't give up hope
he kept walking looking for some sign of
Good Fortune
suddenly he saw a small heart at some
distance could it be a mirage he thought
or maybe just a hallucination
having no other option left he edged
closer only to realize that the heart
is real
uttering the last bits of energy left he
dragged this tired body inside the heart
hoping he could find
the heart was empty and seemed like it
had been abandoned for quite some time
his heart skipped a beat when he saw
what was in the heart
pump
water finally he was overjoyed
it began working the hand pump but no
water came out he tried harder and get
harder no water finally after putting in
every bit of energy he gave up out of
exhaustion and frustration and sat down
thinking maybe I'm just trying to die
out of thirst today and then
secondary of Hope he noticed a bottle in
one corner of the Hut it was filled with
water and caulked up to prevent
evaporation he Uncorked the bottle and
as he was just about to Devour the
life-giving water he noticed a piece of
paper attached to it
the handwritten message read
use this water to start the pump
don't forget to fill the bottle when
you're done he was now in a dilemma to
follow the instruction and pour the
water into the pump
or ignore it and just drink the water
what if you put the water into the pump
and it didn't work
but then maybe the instruction was
correct should you risk it if it turned
out to be false he would be throwing
away the last water he would ever see
have you ever been in a situation like
this where there are only two options
and uncertainty about which one will
work
what will you do which one will you
choose will
you have to choose one and be willing to
bear the consequences that it brings
many people
don't decide because they're fearful of
the consequences and they continue to
remain confused in their life the man
decided to take a leap of faith hands
trembling he poured the water into the
pump closed his eyes said a prayer and
stopped started working the pump he
heard a gurging sound and water came
down gushing out way more than he could
possibly use he drank the cool
refreshing water to his heart's content
and quenched his thirst he was going to
live
feeling much better he looked around the
heart
found a pencil and a map of the region
the map showed that he was still far
away from civilization but at least now
he knew where he was and in which
direction to go next
filled up his flask for the journey
ahead and as per the instruction on the
Note also filled up the bottle and put
the cork back in
and before leaving the hut
he added his own lines below the
instruction
believe me it works most of us may not
be confronted with a situation like this
with the choice made decides whether we
live or die yet we have our own Journeys
to take
own choices to make
the choice we make goes our way
fantastic we can inspire people by
telling them believe me it works and if
it doesn't go our way
we can share our mistakes
our experiences our realizations
and Empower people to make
their right choices if your job pays you
well
okay to overlook the satisfaction you
get from it is it okay to forget your
passion and continue slogging in a job
that you don't like
here's my answer assuming that you spend
on an average about eight hours a day at
work and work a five days a week that
would mean spending 40 hours of your
week at work now assuming that you get
two weeks of holiday every year that
would mean spending 2 000 hours of your
year at work now does that sound a lot
well let's keep going assuming that you
spend 45 years of your life working that
would mean spending a daunting 90 000
precious hours of your life at work
which is approximately 10 years of your
life and if you're not happy with your
work guess what you end up spending
eight hours of your day 40 hours of your
week 2 000 hours of your year 90 000
hours of your life and
entering not sure if that's a great day
I know what you're thinking
following your passion
doesn't pay the bills your calling
doesn't clear the loans and not cages
after all those who slog it out are the
ones who have better cars better houses
better holidays a better life a better
life oh well debatable isn't it I
completely understand and agree that you
can't quit your current job because you
have real needs in the real world but at
the same time I'm also asking you
whether it's fair to spend 10 years of
your life in pain I know that those of
you who are watching this video are
shouting enough of Max sir please tell
us what's the way out here's my proposal
don't take the risk of quitting your
current job to follow your passion what
if the passion stuff doesn't work who
will pay the bills your passion but at
the same time don't neglect your passion
and be a nervous wreck at work try and
find the right balance step one if not
everything
Identify some part of your current work
that you may possibly develops liking
for that will make your 40 hours a week
a little less painful than now
no one has a perfect job exactly like no
one has a perfect partner in marriage
but when you identify those aspects of
your spouse that you love and connect to
that the elements that you don't
necessarily like in your spouse become a
little easy to handle deal with your job
the way you deal with your spouse focus
on and highlight the positives and work
through the negatives step two start
pursuing your passion side by side maybe
it's very small in the beginning maybe
it can be done only over the weekend but
when you do what you love
don't only believe
of satisfaction but also the ability to
handle what you have to do at work
through the week and you know what maybe
one day your passion will become your
profession giving you fulfillment and
the money needed to live in the real
world there were five men who got lost
in a vast Forest
and we're trying to find their way out
the first man said
I'm going to follow my intuition and go
to the left
the second man said
I'm going to go right
I have a strong feeling that that's the
way out
the third man said well I am going to
walk
back on the same path that we took to
reach here I think that would be the
safest the fourth man said I think we
are absolutely on the right track
already and so I'm going to keep walking
straight
after the four men took to the left
the right
back and straight respectively
the fifth man said
well I don't know what to do
I think I'm just going to climb up this
Tall Tree
and get a better view around
before I make up my mind
from the top of the tree the fifth man
could now see
what was the shortest way
to the Village
isn't it a fact that when you rise above
a situation and see the larger picture
your decision seems to be the most sound
well yes indeed
but there's a slight twist to the story
the fifth man thought that the others
should not have chosen the paths they
did and that he was right and they were
wrong and from one point of view
he was right
but from another perspective
I'm not sure
each man had chosen his own path
and gained a different experience
it's not just about right or wrong but
about gaining
your own experience and finding your own
path The Man Who Went left found a long
path but at the end
well it led him to the time
the man who went right
had to fight a pack of wolves but then
he learned how to survive in the forest
the man who went backwards met another
team of hikers
and guess what
he made new friends
the man who went straight
found a farm and was hosted by the
family for a couple of days before
leaving for the village
and of course the man not the tree
found
the shortest path
the journey
enriched each one of them in their own
unique way every decision offers us new
experiences which in turn adds to our
maturity and wisdom ultimately we
Ave our own growth
isn't it set that life is like an exam
people Faith because they try to copy
others not realizing that each one has a
different question paper a different
test ladies and gentlemen walk your own
path
while you also learn from the experience
of others it could be fun to once in a
while revisit your childhood days and
relive them
one day I happen to see a remote
controlled helicopter someone had and
decided to give it a try
having lost practice of using a joystick
it was a little hard in the beginning
but in a few attempts I thought I was
becoming a pro in flying it
it was then that I remembered how a
friend of mine from London had taken me
for a ride on his private plane as we
were taking off I recollect sharing and
inspiring quote with my friends on that
flight I had said when everything seems
to be going against you remember that
the airplane takes off Against the Wind
not with it well the time he says now we
were flying in definitely gave us a real
time experience of that quote as it was
super wobbly during takeoff but we had a
very smooth Landing don't they say all
is well that ends well
recently I decided to try a real
Adventure a one in which you take off in
a plane but don't land in it
skydiving the night before
I'm lying in bed
visualizing myself jumping off the plane
thinking what if the parachute doesn't
open what if it opens but malfunctions
when we are in the air what if I have a
free fall
straight on the ground ladies and
gentlemen do you know what's stopping us
from taking the plunge do you know
what's stopping us from growth
towards what if what if I fail what if I
lose what if people mock me what if he
or she says no what if what if what if
what if life will pass away and our
minds will stop us from realizing our
truest and fullest potential that night
I decided to confront my what if and
shut my mind up I asked myself do you
want the experience of jumping off a
plane
yes came the answer from within
then know what else whatever happens be
ready for it I said to my mind
to make sure it was not an uncalculated
risk I decided to evaluate the risk
factor when I checked the statistics of
skydiving casualties on Google
it was 13 fatalities in 3.3 million
skydives last year way less than the car
accidents that took place last year
but what if
I happen to be one amongst the 13 my
mind protested again that lied down here
in bed snoring and being a couch potato
missing the accelerating experience in
your life I told my mind as I drifted
away into sleep
crossing the crippling boundary of
whatevs I remember telling myself
look darling you're skydiving support
tomorrow is an expert he has had several
years of experience with thousands of
skydives and not a single casualty was
record relax take it easy the next day
as the doors of the plane opened at 18
000 feet above ground level I was ready
telling myself I wanted to do it I can
do it I will do it I remember standing
at the edge of the plane door now
fearlessly looking down and then
foreign
was the most liberating spirits of my
life Liberation from the two paralyzing
words
What if I as we floated in the air
feeling light like never before
parachute opened and I thought to myself
today the parachute is opened so has my
mind open your minds
face those things that are holding you
back
cross the limiting boundaries of your
war deaths believe me an amazing life
Waits ahead on the other side
of what apps there was an old lady who
went to a bank and said to the cashier I
would like to withdraw
five hundred dollars
the female cashier told her I'm sorry
madam for withdrawals of any amount less
than five thousand dollars you may have
to use the ATM actually when the old
lady asked why
the cashier was irritated unknowingly
said Madam look rules are rules here
there's a long cue behind you please let
me do my work
the only lady replied then please help
me withdraw all the money I have
the cashier was astonished when she
checked the account balance
she turned to the old lady
leaned down and said my apologies madam
you have three and a half billion
dollars in your account and a bank does
not have so much cash currently could
you kindly make an appointment and come
again tomorrow please the old lady asked
okay but how much cash can I withdraw
now
the cashier promptly and now
respectfully replied any amount up to
three hundred thousand dollars
the old lady told the cashier that she
wanted to withdraw three hundred
thousand dollars from her account the
cashier did so quickly and handed over
the amount to her
guess what the old lady did she kept
five hundred dollars in her bag and
returned the balance of
299 500 back to the cashier asking her
to deposit it back into the account only
to leave the cashier astonished and
dumbfounded isn't it a fact that way too
often we end up judging a book by its
cover many times people around us
possess the wealth of deep insights
experience wisdom but because of being
caught up with the social standards and
because of bare modest externals we
could easily misjudge and miss out on
the opportunity to receive so much the
next time you're around someone remember
they may possess a wealth that you have
no idea about
stop yourself from judging them and you
may be tremendously benefited by what
they have there were two independent
houses separated by a compound wall
in one lived a young techie
and another an elderly retired man
both of them planted identical saplings
on their respective side of the compound
wall
the young guy supplied his plant with a
lot of water and high quality manure
the retired man however gave his blood
just a small quantity of water and a
little manure
the techies sapling grew into a lush
green leafy robust plant
the retired person's plant was a near
normal but much luxuriant than his
neighbors
one night there was a heavy rain with
Gusty winds and the next morning both
came out to see the fate of their plants
to the techies surprise his plant had
been uprooted whereas his neighbors was
unharmed
the techie turned to the neighbor and
asked why was my plant uprooted by The
Rains despite such good care whereas
yours stayed firm and strong despite
just a little care
the neighbor answered
look young man
you supplied everything the plant would
need in abundance
since the plant did not have to do
anything on its own to search for what
it needed the roots of your plants
haven't gone deep down
I was supplying my blunt just enough to
keep it alive for the rest The Roots had
no choice but to go deep down into the
ground to fulfill its needs since the
roots of your plant were superficial the
rain and wind could easily fell it down
since the roots of my plant were deeply
grounded it could easily withstand this
onslaught of nature isn't the story
similar to the way we deal with our
children with our youngsters sometimes
we can be so possessive and
overprotective of them we can end up
caring for them to the extent of
pampering them not giving them their
space the facility the opportunity and
the impetus to grow by taking
responsibility
on the other hand if we just leave them
to themselves without proper support in
him they may end up making wrong
decisions due to lack of maturity caring
for our children is exactly like caring
for a plant under doing it will make the
Plant die but overdoing it will make the
plant weak it is the right balance that
we make our children go luxuriantly and
bear flowers and fruits in the form of
experience wisdom and maturity
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from sad Guru check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there people think I have
knowledge no my head is empty that's why
to make it look little substantial I
have a turbine it's totally empty always
but I have Clarity Clarity means what
you see things the way they are
knowledge means what